[Music]
524 on your Wednesday morning hey got a
big heads up for anybody planning trips
to Red Rock Canyon and or Pahrump on
Sunday this is for Real from four in the
morning till two in the afternoon you
will not be able to get to or from Red
Rock Canyon on Charleston past the 215
Western Beltway also that same day from
Seven in the morning till one in the
afternoon all of the westbound Lanes of
State Highway 160 toward Pahrump going
to be shut down from Highway 159 a
little bit past Mountain Springs this is
all because of a bicycle race called Le
top Las Vegas by Tour de France so the
closure of the access to Red Rock guess
what else that means that means no
access to the scenic loop the nearby
hiking trails until after two for the
closure of the westbound Lanes of the
main Highway between here and Pahrump
westbound drivers you'll be sharing the
eastbound Lanes withheld from the Nevada
State Police Highway Patrol but the
bottom line is if you don't have to be
out there between 7am and 1 p.m you
might be better off waiting because this
has the potential be a real mess and
this may be one of these driving you
crazy reports that you go back and
review and maybe share it's going to be
on our website 8newsnow.com when you
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone you can join the driving
you crazy conversation at traffic eight
at eightnewsnow.com